foreign
[Music]
myself
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
foreign
Smith is on his heels
Grandpa's gonna be filling his Pampers
right now right I mean don't you think
don't you think that this is uh getting
there
um it seems as if Mark Meadows and we we
talked about this yesterday but we
didn't have all the news all the
confirmation it seemed that Mark Meadows
had flipped and a lot of people assumed
I guess that he took some sort of lesser
deal on charges which still could be
possible right because the the word is
now that there's limited immunity which
means he would have limited immunity to
maybe certain parts
of crimes that he's testifying against
Donald Trump too right
these deals can be complicated
but you know thinking about it it makes
sense now why the Department of Justice
has not done a damn thing
with the referral from the January 6
Select Committee of contempt to Congress
criminal condemned of Congress you
remember that
Peter Navarro Steve Bannon Steve Bannon
still waiting his appeal
um to
to carry out his sentence
but Mark Meadows has not seen the inside
of a courtroom yet nor have it doesn't
seem that the Department of Justice has
moved on the criminal contempt of
congress
everyone was under the assumption that
maybe just maybe that was a sign of Mark
Meadows cooperating well it appears now
that Mark Meadows is cooperating and the
reason why it is so significant
and Mark Meadows uh rather he's rather
he's seeking some sort of immunity or he
has an immunity deal or he's getting a
plea deal or he's pleading to lesser
charges
than Espionage and obstruction uh well
the
it's still him cooperating to the degree
of giving the special counsel the
evidence that they need
to indict Donald Trump now the word is
this is just the word again I want to
caution everyone out there because even
if he gets indicted by Jack Smith on
Espionage and obstruction like we think
he made today or tomorrow
they're saying he they could vote on
these charges today that doesn't mean
we're actually going to see them
publicly I mean that just means that it
may be Trump's team leaking definitely
for sure 100 this is Trump Trump's team
leakingness
this is Trump's Mo it was his entire Mo
when he was president he was always like
leakers leakers leakers leakers leakers
and leakers this and leaked that and he
was the one leaking the [__]
so that he could wine [__] and complain
and this is the same thing I mean we
sent out a fraud social post talking
about how no one has told him that
there's charges coming that there's
indictments no one has told them that
that he's the target he hasn't been told
that well then why have you been
bitching this whole time
why have you been [__] rage posting
on fraud social then dummy if no one has
told you that you're a Target
investigation why have you been saying
you're the target of a Witch Hunt
investigation come on give me a [__]
break
this isn't this isn't rocket surgery
Jesus Christ
but he's at the end of the line here it
seems with Jack Smith getting ready to
indict him now again there could be a
lot of different situations folks so
don't don't get too uh crazy
if it doesn't happen as faster it's
exactly like you want it to happen
and what I mean by that is Donald Trump
is not going to see the inside of a jail
cell
anytime soon
any anytime soon even if he goes to
trial and he's convicted folks
he's a former president United States it
is likely that a federal judge even with
these charges outstanding if he gets a
conviction it is likely that a judge
will let him go to house arrest until he
seeks appeal I mean that's possible a
lot of things are possible that's going
to piss you off
the one thing that is not
going to
be a surprise though is when the country
rejects him not the Republican party you
gotta remember we're in a Republican
primary I I would imagine if if there is
indictments soon and they are announced
publicly it will solidify
it will it it will make sure to codify
him as the nominee he will Propel to the
Republican nomination of the criminal
criminal America First Nazi party
that's where he's going to go what I
mean who else is going to who else is
going to win
Mike Pence
Mike Pence it talks about a two-tier
justice system yesterday on his stupid
[__] town hall on CNN after his
announcement
his Saltine announcement to run for
president he goes on CNN and he
describes the two-tier justice system
that maga's bitching about he describes
it right on the open I'm gonna show you
the [__] clip today that guy ain't
gonna [__] win they wanted to hang
that [__] because he didn't do
what the what orange Mussolini Jesus
wanted him to do the cult leader he
didn't listen to The Cult leader so he's
no longer part of the cult
Ron DeSantis it when When Donald Trump
is indicted
on what could be Espionage charges Ron
DeSantis ain't gonna lay a [__]
finger on him he'll eat pudding with
three fingers but he's not gonna lay a
finger on Donald Trump because their
entire [__] personality
is that Democrats are weaponizing the
government against Republicans
it only it only weakens Ron DeSantis to
continue that messaging but he continues
it
he continues it the same with Mike Pence
now you might say well Chris Christie
could land a punch
he could really go after him sure
absolutely I actually think that that is
the only person that is going to attack
Donald Trump in this moment for being a
[__] Criminal
is Chris Christie
that's that that's who is going to be
the person
because Chris Christie really doesn't
have anything to gain or lose
by attacking him
I mean you may say well Tony you're
saying that DeSantis won't attack him so
that means that he won't win yes that's
what I'm saying
and you're saying if Chris Christie
attacks him that means
he won't he does attack him he won't win
yes that's what I'm saying you have to
remember how manga views Chris Christie
Maga views Chris Christie is an enemy
they might have used Chris Christie
almost the same way we view Chris
Christie but the only the only thing the
only thing that he wants his power you
don't give a [__] about principles
and then they make the fat jokes right
Chris Christie's dead in the water
here
but my my prediction is
just like just like I predicted when he
was [__] indicted on 34 felony counts
of business fraud in New York it
wouldn't hurt him it would help him just
like when his business that he ran for
decades and decades and decades with
Criminal Intent was found guilty on 17
counts of business fraud and fined over
a million dollars and his CFO went to
Rikers
on felony charges
it didn't phase him it only helped him
because they're going to be like oh this
political this political this even the
Ron DeSantis supporters are gonna have a
difficult time
unwinding their [__] stupid lies
about weaponizing government they're
gonna have a really tough time it's
going to be difficult they they didn't
see this coming and the reason why is
because their only personality trait is
to own the libs at every measure no
matter what no matter what they have to
say no matter how what kind of dumb
[__] they have to tether themselves
to they'll do it
and they did it with this weaponation
weaponization of government it's peer
projection
pure projection I mean [__] Grandpa
Poopypants was calling on Congress to
save his ass he knows his cult ain't
gonna save his ass
they're not gonna they're not gonna do
it January 6th style thing again I know
everyone says that no no they're not
that's all a bunch of [__]
they're that the lot of them that was
willing to commit
a certain uh willing to commit a certain
level of felony for this [__]
have already done that and a lot of them
have their feet on a co-prison floor
right now
as we speak
some of them have already had their feet
on a cold prison floor
so this idea this idea that somehow his
[__] cult is Gonna Save him get the
[__] out of here
get the [__] out of here the proud boys
are broken up they can't decide what's
racist and what's not and how racist how
racist is racist and Who Wants to Be
Where The Oath Keepers are are a [__]
disgrace
maga's being divided up into Maca and
gak with Ron DeSantis
we can't we can't seem to figure out
that Republicans suck at governing
and they're terrible at it that's why
they can't even they can't even pass
rules on the house floor for some dumb
[__] stupid no woke stoves Act
they can't even accomplish their own
[__] political theater
that's how [__] an epic government
they really truly are
they can't even they can't even make it
to where we believe
that they have some
some sort
of idea of what the institution of
government should be
and this is all good for our democracy I
I understand that a lot of people are
you know anxious
about whether this is going to change
the Paradigm and shift the Paradigm When
Donald Trump is indicted on federal
charges let me let me clue you in on
this and I've been saying this I'm I'm
trying to prepare you for this
it's not gonna happen the way you think
is gonna happen is they're just gonna be
like ah [__] Trump [__] him we're gonna
move on it's not gonna happen that way
folks
listen the reason why I go into a lot of
those Twitter spaces and listen to their
[__] absolute dribble and nonsense
because folks that's where the delusion
starts
that's what the delusion snowball Works
off of
and it perpetuates and perpetuates and
perpetuates through this Q Anon Facebook
Twitter Loop
that is absolutely riding these people's
fascist brains
but it's real
it's real the delusion I mean
the delusion is real
and I'm telling you 100 without a doubt
they will support him and Propel him to
be the nominee when he is indicted on
federal charges he's already setting it
up he's already giving them the
narrative he's feeding them the lines
that they need to say on social media to
make it seem like he still has support
because in the end all he has to do is
win the delegates that's it
he just has to win the first several
rounds of delegates and he's the nominee
and that's why he continues to say he
won he didn't lose so there's an
incumbency factor and with pile that on
top of affiliation vote and the hatred
the pure-blooded hatred of the
Republican Party he will be the nominee
it's crazy
like just think about it
think about the time that we [__]
live in
that one group of people in this country
absolutely
100 percent
believe
absolute outright [__] lies
it's insanity
it's Insanity I mean
provable lies like this isn't hard stuff
right
and and and some people out there are
still both sizing stuff
um I I went after Joe Walsh this morning
when when he tweeted something about
down the middle
Joe dude Joe man there is no down the
middle stop bull sizing [__] there are
no both sides you [__] idiot
there are no both sides
there's only one group of people who are
interested in democracy and they do not
affiliate with Republicans or Maga
if you're still affiliating with Maga or
Republicans you do not believe in
democracy you do not want democracy you
want authoritarianism you want fascism
we understand it we get it you can just
admit it out loud it's cool
we know
that was the one thing that is a little
bit of the difference right of like
1930s Germany or or Italy even like they
were like yeah we're [__] fascist you
goddamn right we are I mean I I like my
Nazis to be a little open
right I want them to be proud of their
fascism these [__] [__] bags now they
run around
costuming costuming the [__] swastika
with the with the [__] cross right
the [__] out of here with that [__] I
mean I I'm an atheist but I you know I I
really don't like religion in the first
place in general
but when you use your [__]
Christianity
and you use you bastardize your
Christian morals to justify your hatred
and your fascism it really is come on
come on
people aren't dead [__] it's no
wonder [__] Church attendance is down
it's no wonder so many people are
absolutely not interested and have
anything to do with their Church inside
their [__] government
or their government
promoting a certain [__] Church
I mean there is there is legal and
constitutional reasons for separation a
church and state but also you know just
so you don't throw up in your mouth it
kind of is a good thing too right I mean
it's [__] disgusting
to tie your certain [__] morals and
how you view a certain religion
and force everyone else you know they're
always saying that [__] right
you know what I mean they're always like
oh you're forcing this agenda down our
throat no what we're saying is leave
them alone we're saying sleep alone just
shut the [__] up and leave them alone
man move on go try to [__] figure out
how to govern and fix Health Care maybe
bring the energy
and the hatred that you have for certain
groups of people bring that for I don't
know health insurance companies
medical groups that are overcharging
people maybe you know to get to get
Americans affordable [__] health care
for crying out loud so they don't go
broke because of a medical bill I'm not
saying that's the most important issue
but hell that's a [__] easy one
that's low hanging for root right if
you're gonna direct your outrage and
your anger towards something
you don't think the American people are
going to support you when you direct it
towards insurance companies come on who
the [__] is lower on the totem blo poll
of scumbags than insurance companies I
don't give a [__] which one it is I mean
you may like your local agent for your
house insurance or something but Jesus
Christ
when you have to file a claim or you get
a [__] bill and it's wrong and you
got to make the phone call come on you
[__] hate it right this is all a
common [__] enemy that we could all
have across the board across the
political Spectrum
and they could a hundred percent
Focus just a lot just a little bit yes I
had a [__] drop of the energy that
they focus on [__] books women's
Banning Women's Healthcare burning books
School curriculum and math where it says
CRT
[__] putting their churches in our
schools and our public institutions and
governing with their [__] Bible
verses
telling people who they can and can't
love just just that energy that you
[__] have that that that
urge for fascism and that hatred and you
know aim it towards again the health
insurance industry
we'll get behind you with that right
they can't
they can't folks because they have the
woke mind virus like Rhonda santises
they have the woke mind virus
it is a [__] disease fascism is
an American fascism trumpism Maga
is a goddamn heavy disease that is
difficult to get rid of
but they do they have woke mine virus
and that is why he will be the nominee
and I know it's frustrating and I know
you know a lot of people are going to be
pissed off when he's charged with
Espionage and the guys out walking
around
and he's out campaigning he's gonna piss
people off people going to be mad you're
going to be tweeting about it you're
going to be [__] writing about it I'm
going to be
screaming about it into a microphone
but it's going to happen you should
expect it I mean there could always be
the situation where
I'm completely wrong
and they lock him up
well how bad would that be
if I was wrong I mean I mean I really I
really am with these things because I
just I see them so clearly I've been
watching politics for so long
and I feel like I have my my finger on
the pulse of average American people and
what the [__] they want and what they
don't want and what they don't want is
some [__] who is selling
documents to some other country for
money because he's broke
president or [__] otherwise okay we
don't want it it's not a thing that we
want and we're definitely not going to
give you the job as president
but the Republicans will nominate him
they'll give him the job as nominee
folks I I would say
that if if my predictions are correct
and Donald Trump is their nominee and
these indictments Propel him to that
which I believe that they're going to
I I believe after these indictments the
other thing the force that is going to
be magnetic towards him being the
nominee is when the Trump ladites the
megalodites
these [__] fascists these are real
America First Nazis do not abandon him
tax affiliation
that's what that is
and I would say anyone considering
voting for Ron DeSantis in a primary
after they watch all their family all
their Maga friends all their Maga
cohorts on social media
wherever the the deepest darkest parts
of social media that they may be
when they see these networks talking
about how it's all a Witch Hunt and
they're just after him
and everyone's solidifying around him
that it's all [__] and they're just
trying to get at him and any other
Republican
affiliation will kick in
they will abandon Mike Pence
they will abandon Ron DeSantis Chris
Christie ain't got a shot in Hell nor
Haley North Scott North Hutchinson or
whoever that [__] from North
Dakota is that where he's from who is
this [__]
some guy from North Dakota is running
for I don't know it's [__] weird
he will be the nominee when he gets
indicted it's going to secure it
that's the way it is I I don't want to
tell you I mean I wish it wasn't that
way and I hope I'm wrong I hope I'm
wrong I hope I hope Jack Smith locks him
up never lets him out the Republican
Party decides to nominate someone like
Mike Pence that Joe Biden can whip the
pants off of sure fine let's do that I'm
good with that I actually believe that
Mike Pence has a better chance of being
nominee than Ron DeSantis
that listen to me listen I actually
believe that Mike Pence has a better
chance
of being the nominee than Ron DeSantis
two reasons Mike Pence is willing to
throw a punch on Trump
and Mike Pence will attract the
evangelicals
I don't tell you
that's just I mean have you have do you
have an Evangelical uncle
you know what I'm talking about you know
that [__] you know what I'm
talking about he's always talking about
God and religion and the Bible and [__]
you're like dude
we're in a Wendy's man order what you've
ordered the cheeseburger you want Jesus
Christ stop talking about the [__]
Bible for five seconds and order your
food
that [__] That's Mike Pence
that's him
and they'll vote they'll definitely
[__] vote for the person they see
that's them how do you think how do you
think Trump ultimately courted the
evangelicals in 2016. I mean that was
the goal with Mike Pence was the court
the evangelicals
and the Flies attract the Flies I'm so
glad you're here with me on this
Thursday Thursday Thursday it's it's
still pride month it's still June it's
only June 8th
I want to give you guys an opportunity
here to see the [__] Pride logo that
we came up with by request from the
audience uh Miss loveseat brought it up
at first I believe and then everyone
piled on said they wanted a design for
pride month uh so our co-host Gabe
Sanchez came up with this design we put
it on a t-shirt we've got it on fanny
packs to go to
store.dtonymichaels.com that's
store.dtonymichaels.com and get your
[__] Pride merch t-shirt and fanny
pack today today also don't forget to
check out the let them meet rake oh
they're gonna need a ton of rake over
the next week you think this week was
great I mean like this week has turned
out great I haven't I haven't even
gotten to the pat Robinson store yet oh
my God oh my God speaking of religion
speaking of religious you're a religious
Uncle what about your what about your
Evangelical Grandad oh man Pat Robertson
took a dirt nap
[Music]
so sad
you did more more evil in this world
and then good that is wrapped up in the
book he used to spread that evil [__]
him [__] Pat Robertson and what he's
done to this [__] country [__] him
that's right I said it I don't give a
[__] I'll piss and [__] all over his
grave he gets no sympathy for me for
what he did to this country what he did
to the Republican party and white
Evangelical Christians [__] you you
piece of [__] garbage you trash good
it's about goddamn time I can't
understate how
unlucky we are that he lived to be 93
[__] years old
a lot of people hack me on that oh my
God you're so rough on him what the [__]
get the [__] out of here have you ever
listened to the vile [__] that
[__] said him and Jerry fall
well after 9 11. I'll play the I'll play
you the [__] clip and see how how how
oh Tony you're outrageous you're saying
good it's good that Pat Robertson is
dead um I'll show you the clip I'll show
you what I mean so don't go anywhere
we're gonna play Clips we're gonna do it
all right here at the Tony Michaels butt
guess you know every single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific for two full hours on
YouTube make sure you subscribe right
now go follow us on Twitter at Tony
Michaels pod download every single
episode in the afternoon on Apple's
Spotify in Google and if you're
wondering where you can watch besides
YouTube you can go over to Facebook
follow at the Tony Michaels that's at
the Tony Michaels on Facebook also I
want to thank everyone for following us
and subscribing on Twitch
great Support over there we're building
our audience and building the chat over
on Twitch to go to twitch.tv slash the
Tony Michaels that's twitch.tv Tony
Michaels and if you wanna
link your Amazon Prime account to your
Twitch account you can give us a free
two dollars every month that's right if
you got a Prime account you can give us
it's about two bucks I think it's like
two dollars and seven cents or some [__]
by the time they take their fees and
they're cut
for you if you have a Prime account you
just link your Amazon Prime account to
your Twitch account and you give us that
one free subscription you get with
Amazon gaming in your Amazon Prime
account the directions are on our
website you just go to the Tony
michaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com the directions are like the
fourth one down we got the merch store
link there as well as well as my patreon
link so check that all out don't go
anywhere we'll be right back
right after this I love the boycott
binder
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
trying to remember all the things you
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with ease
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott binder
for just 29.99 plus you'll also receive
our next rep as a bonus just Loop it
around your neck to travel with ease but
call right now and we'll double the
offer that's two boycott binders and two
neck straps for just 29.99 boycott
binders brought to you by the same
makers of binders full of women
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show people are
asking about the boycott binder
in the chat you know what we should do
while I'm waiting on game Sanchez we
should shoot the ship
that's right just a random shoot this
[__] right here right now on the Tony
Michaels podcast if you got a question
throw it in the chat whether on YouTube
Facebook or twitch if you're on Twitter
I'm sorry I'm sorry I can't help you and
not a lot of people watch on Twitter
right they don't and the reason why is
because the what is left of periscope
that we stream through to Twitter is
absolute [__] garbage
you know um a lot there's a lot of talk
about Tucker Carlson's little video the
other day but I I'm not going to get
into the weeds with Tucker but I want to
talk about the media and how people view
the media and and that's one subject
that we're going to talk about with Gabe
today I think I want to bring it up he
was in the space last night and they
were talking about this but when we
stream to Twitter
and maybe maybe we should stop doing it
I don't know I mean it doesn't cost me
any extra to do it takes me a little
extra time
um to put it up but when we stream this
show to Twitter the only reason why I do
it is because it has the website link
and the YouTube link for the day so you
can just you can see it you can hear now
Tony's on so then you just click the the
[__] link and it takes you to a
better place to watch it
because Twitter's horrible at watching
media that's not really how it was
designed
it's an archive not a guide right like
that's the whole it's a timeline so just
it doesn't work that well when you're
talking about
when you're when you're talking
about video media that's longer than 30
seconds 60 seconds two minutes
so anyways okay let's see well there was
a question about the boycott binder
someone said did he come up with the
boycott binder Gabe and he did
um he did come up with uh the boycott
binder now he did come up with a boycott
binder like two years ago and we used to
play it on the show a long time ago
um MJ mjn I don't know if MJ's in the
chat right now but I think she knows for
sure if we if I used to play boycott
binder you know like a year and a half
ago
um but but we we we we
scaled back to just a few commercials
now we used to have one
um that was called the droop it had to
do with uh wearing a mask or something
or wearing a mask correctly
um so we we scale back on that one but
but for weeks and weeks and weeks as
this boycott [__] on went on when
they're like Bud Light Target and
rainbows and they're scary and all that
kind of [__]
um I was like man we really need to be
bring back boycott binder because it's
perfect for the time like some of these
things a Gabe does are completely
Evergreen he's got a lot of videos
they're like he can just replay two
years later and it's the same old stick
just a different kind of [__] angle
right it's the same old right-wing
[__] stick right the same lies the
same stupid [__] outrage over over
[__] that doesn't make any sense
and he can just replay the video
I mean to some degree you're like is
this new or is this old because it kind
of has a little different taste to it
because it was a little different time
in their stupid foe outrage right when
they get [__] fake upset about
rainbows at Target oh my God they
printed rainbows on clothes at Target
and they put them in one particular
section and put the word pride on it oh
my God that's the end of the
civilization as we know it
[__] boneheads
but boycott binder works so well in that
and maybe maybe we should do like a
like a a new boycott binder like an
updated you know like they make one
product remember the ShamWow guy the
shamlai Sham wow and then they have like
ShamWow Ultra or ShamWow you know
whatever it is but that would make sense
if we did boycott binder Ultra so maybe
maybe we should get we could get that
going
um oh um someone's asking about
um the poster Muhammad Ali yeah so if
you see the poster there that's Muhammad
Ali
so that's Muhammad Ali and Sonny Liston
and it's uh May 27 1965.
first minute first round that's one of
the famous pictures of Muhammad Ali
so it just it gives me inspiration you
know what I mean
um to not [__] around don't mess around
just just do it just do it just get it
done in the first minute in the first
round
especially if you're gonna you know
punch up some Nazis
let's see
um what are the questions that we have
in the um in the chat
we're shooting the [__] right now so if
you got a question through it and chat
and we'll try to get you an answer here
I I kind of do the same sort of thing on
patreon it's called ask me anything on
patreon but it's a little different
where when I do ask me anything on
patreon I answer like all the questions
and in a 30 minute period so
that's the
um am I a Cubs fan no I'm a Cardinals
I'm from Missouri
the [__] wrong with you
are you kidding me I mean I can be a
liberal in Missouri and you know get
death threats but if I was a [__]
Cubs fan in Missouri holy [__] what the
[__] um someone said thoughts on Bannon
hey that's a good subject Luke Luke done
Inc here said uh dance on Bannon
um
Steve Bannon is uh a sludgy slimy piece
of [__]
and he'll turn
on Donald Trump for sure
just like he turned on Roger Stone you
know that's why Roger Stone [__]
hates Steve Bannon I mean hates that
[__]
and the reason why is because Steve
Bannon kind of turned on Roger Stone so
um who's the guy that does my intro
um it's it's a guy hired he does a lot
of radio voices and stuff
um and he he's done a lot of he he does
the uh the intro the outro that was
original and the the intro that I have
in the outro that I have
is original to the show that's the very
first one we've had we've always kept it
I want to continue to keep it I love the
intro I love the outro I don't I don't
think I ever want to get rid of it
but he's done the bumpers on the
commercials so when you hear
um the bumpers which is the music
leading out to the commercial and
leading into the show he does the
bumpers too so we need to get some new
bumpers done
yeah we need to get some new bumpers
done
um that way we can
we can be up to date I guess maybe get
some different stuff
oh there there's the Cubs
um question no I'm not a not a Cubs fan
I've been to a lot of uh Cubs Cardinals
games and you know what's funny is when
I was younger we we would go to Old Bush
Stadium
um and we would sit in the bleacher
section because we were [__] broke we
were young and we wanted to be able to
afford beer too but but we'd sit in the
bleacher section and it didn't matter
who the Cardinals were playing right
didn't matter who the Cardinals are
playing there would always be a Cubs fan
they're booing the Cardinals and rooting
for the other team that's kind of how it
is between the Cubs and the Cardinals
I'm sure it's the same way
at Wrigley I could ask Gabe I think Gabe
is a uh is a Cubs fan you know he's from
Chicago no one's perfect right
I'm just saying I mean when we're
talking about baseball what do you want
from me man Cardinals won last night by
the way
let's see what other questions
um do we have here
um
mro says we want chaos in the Republican
Party absolutely that's not a question
but you are correct
um that is absolutely what we want and
we have to not not just chaos right so
um they're gonna have a lot of it
a lot of it over the next year year and
a half
but what we have to do is we have to
exploit it
right
you have to exploit
that chaos you have to draw wedges
into that chaos right so you really
Stoke it it's almost like pouring
gasoline on a book burning fire you know
what I mean you know what I mean that
kind of thing we really need to pour
gasoline on their chaos fire over at the
Republican party and it really is not
that difficult that's again one of the
reasons why I go in those Twitter spaces
is because they're always [__]
fighting right you get the DeSantis Camp
you get the Trump Camp you get this
Trump supporter that Trump supporter you
get this person and that person and
they're all essentially on the same side
right and that what liberals and
leftists always say oh we're on the same
side
well they're on the same side too we
just have to find what sides they're not
the same on
we have to point those out we have to
exploit them even if it's a little you
know disingenuous of us to do it we have
to engage in our democracy we have to
play to win folks
we ha have you ever been playing a board
game with your family right
I remember playing a board game with
your family and you had to make a move
that really man up
it was a good form but to win the game
and to sink someone's Battleship maybe
maybe it's battleships you're playing I
don't know
you had to go through with it
but just feel a little bit that's how
it's gonna be
sad's gotta be [__] it you gotta win we
have to win this game we this this is
not just whether we get bragging rights
on whether we run family gain game night
with Monopoly this is our [__]
democracy this is our way of life
this is our children's this is our
children's country our grandchildren's
country
right
much more is at stake here so yeah
should we take the gloves off
and win first round first minute
like Muhammad Ali absolutely we should
absolutely we should
um some someone's asking here I guess
about the P the PGA
um you know I I don't know golf that
well to be quite nice I don't follow I
don't give a [__] I could care less
um about the PGA
I really don't give a [__] never been
that into golf in the first place I was
never good at it
never had a liking to it I didn't
understand why you'd run around a
[__] huge course chasing a little
ball with a [__] Crooked Stick but
whatever some people enjoy it some
people like it and you know and some
people like to watch it whatever yeah it
is what it is
but when the live tournament which is
saudi-backed uh and a poor a for-profit
group that owns the live tournament
when they're tied to Trump tied to Jared
Kushner tied to the Saudis that I don't
know flew planes and uh buildings in New
York on 9 11.
um it does seem and
and and they're [__]
protecting bone salt from khashoggi's
murder listen
it is a little suspicious
that the PGA and non-profit organization
somehow is going to merge with a
for-profit organization right
now what what the what the [__]
banter back and forth between the live
golfers and the non-live golfers is at
you know I don't really know I never I
didn't get into the ins and outs of who
wanted what because apparently the live
tournament paid a lot of golfers a lot
of blood money to come play for them
and a lot of the big PGA guys said [__]
you I ain't taking your blood Money
just to swing a golf club I mean a lot
of these guys have enough money that
that their grandchildren won't run out
of it right I mean Tiger Woods won't run
out of it
it won't it won't run out of it
so as far as it goes though it seems
like though
that there's probably gonna I I'm just
I'm just saying when you get Saudi dirty
money and [__] and then you get Trump
involved in this thing where he's the
one who brought the live tournament to
the United States to his at his golf
courses
I'm just telling you someone's going to
get indicted somewhere for this thing
there's going to be federal indictments
that has to do with the merger between
live and PGA I'm almost assured of it
what other questions do we get
oh you're asking someone else someone
said plaid shorts I'm like no I don't
wear plaid shorts
I guess you're asking about the live
turn
um what do you think what um what do I
think about the the wildfires you mean
in Canada I mean obviously
um you know we're at a point of
with climate change we're at a point
that you know we can't just start
turning back and get a noticeable
difference but it's pretty obvious that
climate change has a lasting effect on
large groups of people
win win it when it definitely has I
think there's a hundred wildfires in
Canada that they're still trying to put
out
and and uh New York City yesterday and
I'm not sure how it is today but
yesterday
it was um I mean you couldn't even see
in New York City from some of the
pictures it was and it was like orange
we just kind of weird I like when Donald
Trump is gonna get indicted this big
huge orange Cloud descends on New York
City isn't that really I mean honestly
if if you were a conspiracy theorist
wouldn't you be like oh my God maybe
he's the Antichrist this big huge orange
clown of smoke
is descending on New York City when he's
losing his mind as Jack Smith prepares
to indict the [__] right I mean
if you were a conspiracy theorist that's
the way your mind should be going
I mean hey you know I'm not trying to
[__] start anything or start some big
conspiracy theory that the the orange
cloud of darkness is descending on New
York City because the orange Mussolini
Jesus is about to be indicted but you
know whatever you want to do
but a lot of a lot of Republicans of
course are taking advantage of this
politically by bashing you know AOC and
allegor and others and John Kerry when
they say that this is a result of
climate change
I mean it is it is a result of climate
change everything is a result
of climate change in our environment and
I don't I don't know if you understand
that or not regardless of how it's
changing or why it's changing or how
much it's changing and I'm not doubting
that it's that it's done by human causes
I'm just saying if if we can't even
agree that our environment
is affected by climate change when it
happens you you aren't even on the same
Planet as us you're not Tethered to any
sort of reality
this idea that climate change has to be
fake because I can't believe that humans
are way humans aren't capable of
destroying the Earth and listen the
truth of the matter really is is that
the humans aren't going to destroy the
planet we're going to destroy the
ability to live
on the planet you got it
we're not going to destroy the planet
okay the planet will live long past us
long past us
the planet is just gonna be a place that
we can't live I mean I don't know if
you've seen New York City yesterday but
God damn the air quality there it
wouldn't take very long if that was the
air quality all around the planet
for us not to be here much longer
I mean really honestly that's [__]
scary [__] now luckily
that this is caused by an event in
Canada with wildfires and I say luckily
because we're lucky that this isn't just
the air quality in general right I mean
maybe I'm off my rocker here maybe Gabe
Sanchez can let me know if I'm off my
rocker am I off my rocker or do you have
any idea what the hell I'm talking about
I don't know you talking about the
wildfires I'm talking about yeah well
that here more more importantly the air
quality in New York City
because I mean obviously the wildfires
are one cause of something somewhere and
then because of the wildfires now
there's this big huge orange cloud of
trump darkness that is descending on New
York City I I think that the conspiracy
theorist should go should we call
Infowars and Alex Jones and see if we
can say that it's and say that it's a
what a trump fart that just like loomed
over New York City well you know it's I
I Gabe it seems a little coincidental
well I can tell you this much so like
living in California obviously we have
wildfires right right and in 2020 we
well actually there's there have been
two occasions living in California
uh me personally now there have been you
know previous years as well but
um there have been two occasions where
smoke
from the wildfires caused the sky to
turn orange right there was one slight
one and what was it was it was it
anywhere severe is what we're seeing in
New York right now yeah so 2020 there
was one 2020 there were severe fires
that were happening and the same thing
happened I remember that I I just don't
remember I mean I mean I guess there in
because the fire was in California and
it was burning down like [__]
neighborhoods like it would come into a
like just a average old suburban
cul-de-sac and they would just burn that
[__] thing to the ground it was that
was more the focus of like the reporting
it's like Jesus Christ these people are
being displaced well no there was there
was reporting after because it was like
oh uh yeah these fires are happening but
then it was the the actual air quality
right and looking at it to be like oh
you shouldn't go out if you don't
actually have like so you experienced
yourself personally the air yeah yeah I
mean I I walked out of my apartment in
the sky honestly like there's like I
said there two occasions one when I
lived in SF and it looked like Blade
Runner and it was like a toned down
version of what I experienced in LA in
2020 2020 was
uh was the exact same thing as what
we're seeing in in New York City
um
it's it was insane I mean to walk
outside and literally be like this looks
like Blade Runner right well like this
looks like [__] uh Total Recall right
like we it looks like we're on Mars
right now where the sun is like you
could look at the Sun and not have to
worry that like uh I can't look at it
because it was so glossed over by all
the orange
the the smoke the residue all that stuff
I mean it smelled like a giant campfire
that's how close we were to the fires
that were happening
um
so it's it's CR it's you know I I
sympathize with the people of new I mean
obviously everyone in Canada but I also
sympathize with those who are in the
midwest uh because Colorado got a little
bit it the Midwest got a little bit of
it and then obviously New York got the
worst well we're we're still like here
in Missouri because I'm in Central
Missouri and it's like uh it's really
hazy you know what I mean yeah yeah it's
almost like like a midday fog but it's
not really fog you know what I mean
that's that's what it seems like it's
pretty orange it was it was pretty crazy
to live through those few days where it
was like it was like building up hit a
peak where it was just like a orange
Wasteland and then fade out but still it
was one of those things where you know
it was
wearing you know having coveted wearing
masks and then also having this fire at
the same time being like well I'm
already you know already wearing this
stuff uh because it was like September
September 2020. it was like September
9th or September 10th or 11th or
something like that it was uh 2020 is
when those fires were happening and when
that smoke came through la
um
I would be remiss in my duty if I did
not follow through on a promise so the
other yeah two days ago there was a I
just want to quickly talk about there
was it two days ago there was a Twitter
space that had the Q Anon Shaman in it
okay really and I wanna yeah yeah what's
his name what's his name Jacob uh
Chandler yeah chancelly chancelly yeah
yeah Jacob it's Jacob's something
Champion Jacob coxley yeah and uh and
Kalyn Kalyn as well as Ty was in there
Kalyn was in there with the Twitter
space in the Twitter space and of course
no one could speak I mean I requested I
just Spam requested to speak so what is
it was it Mario's spaces some other guy
and it was also it was Jesus but just
because I meant to mention it yesterday
uh but basically
um the Twitter space that they had was
[__] nuts man like if you thought
Jacob chancelly was already crazy would
be like oh man Q sent me I went to the
Capitol holy [__] man he was on some
crazy tangent where he was talking about
the cabal adrenochrome uh Q uh he was
talking about Hollywood sex Rings he was
talking about different movies and and
the sexual nature of them and then of
course
and then of course people were taught
and then and then uh uh because of this
is actually relevant it was it was
trending later that night Mel Gibson so
Mel Gibson who was recently photographed
with uh with Carrie Lake right he's
supposed to have some exposed the 34
billion dollar sex trafficking ring out
of Ukraine and Hollywood and all this
stuff Mel Gibson did this Mel yeah Mel
Gibson is supposed to is is it
surprising that Mel Gibson is a Cuban
honor though is it really I mean right I
mean anti-Semitism I mean right that's
what I'm saying it's like it's not hard
for an anti-semite like Mel Gibson to
buy Q Anon right I mean someone who
isn't like steeped in anti-Semitism it
may take a little bit for it to catch on
you know and really really get its grip
on them but like an anti-semite who just
oh no yeah oh I mean they're like [__]
yeah I'd buy that [__] Jewish places are
you kidding me sure that's alcohol
that's the thing it's like with Q you're
never like full-on anti-Semitism right
right you buy in they're like oh here's
this problem and then this is right it
just has those undertones right right
those undertones are a good sell for
someone who's an outright anti-semit
yeah yeah no children whoa this makes me
feel great and I don't actually have to
say I hate the Jews out loud like
exactly that's that's why they love Q
Anon because it's so it's so like a thin
veil
here's so here's what happened uh and
then we can move on but basically and
because supposedly Mel Gibson is is
creating this four-part docu-series
right that's supposed to expose this
billion dollar sex trafficking ring out
of years this is like a Netflix series I
have no idea I I I didn't know anyone
was still working with Mel Gibson uh
well he's also making I mean ever since
he made passion to Christ man he's been
able to fund whatever he wants because
he [__] took that to the bank after
Studios were like we're not making a
movie about Jesus and then he
self-funded and he made a [__] [__]
ton of movie uh money uh so anyway Jacob
Chancey was like all this other stuff
about how these people are [__]
pedophiles and groomers and this and
that and you know where he stopped and
said oh well actually in this one
situation oh Mel Gibson is actually I
see
and then he says Mel Gibson is actual
because the the guy who was also on
there as a host was like oh well yeah
Mel Gibson and this and that and he's
like yeah yeah
but Mel Gibson uh I believe is more or
less Undercover
and caught for those things because he
is trying to reveal what's going on so
basically so wait wait wait this is a
this is a really this is a really shitty
movie plot it sounds like like this is
this is like like Donnie bransco you
remember that movie with Johnny Depp and
Al Pacino where he's the undercover oh
yeah yeah yeah Donny Brown and he falls
in he falls he basically Falls for Al
Pacino's character and he's really a
really good friend with him and he's
he's really he's like oh man I gotta
[__] I gotta arrest him and I'm
actually a cop and it's kind of hard for
him to do that you know and what do they
call it Stockholm syndrome but it's the
reverse yeah exactly exactly so you're
saying that they're like oh Mel Gibson
is undercover in the cabal and all the
things that he's doing he's only doing
to expose the calls yeah exactly yeah so
like anyone anyone that you like there
was another person that was hilarious
isn't this funny though I mean you know
a lot of people like oh my God this is
crazy I'm like yeah but come on man I
mean most people are gonna be like what
the [__] are you talking about can you
imagine can you imagine being like a
party with a bunch of friends and some
guys stand around saying this [__] to
you you're like what the f who the [__]
is this guy yeah yeah who invited this
[__] to to us we would so like
he goes on and he like defends Mel
Gibson and there was someone else where
he's like oh I don't know if those
people are actually bad because they're
the ones who are going to be revealing
or exposing these things and there was
one part
there was one part that Caitlyn mentions
here he was talking about a woman having
her butt cheek sliced off on a grill at
a barbecue for Elites there was some
movies
you're talking about Hannibal Lecter
style like like a like a like an Arby's
meat it's like just like yeah and then
we got the meats you know how how thick
are they cutting it to grill it on it
that's why I don't know I don't know if
there's if you slice
or tenders like but that's what I'm
saying if you slice it way too thin it's
gonna be really hard to grill right like
I mean you may be able to put it like on
aluminum foil if you put foil over your
grill and then you might all I'm saying
is like you're doing a salmon or a
really I'm just saying I'm just I'm just
trying to think you're gonna slice off
some chick's butt cheek and you're gonna
Grill it I'm just trying to be logical
here right as as I I can I know I get it
I get it but you're trying to find logic
in something that well I mean obviously
obviously but I can tell you listening
and anyone else in the chat who is
listening uh to this Twitter space was
yes butt flanks Patrick says butt flanks
oh my God it was it was insane because
he was all over the place and the guy
that was there is like the host was like
oh yeah totally uh-huh that's crazy and
then Jacob's like yeah yeah and then
there was this other movie and it was
like why are you watching these movies
like why are you
yeah
John gross here on YouTube says Tony are
you writing a cookbook I don't Gabe
that's not a bad idea a q Anon cookbook
just saying Chef Q Chef Q there you go
you're saying
could be could be a good commercial
anyway I just wanted to bring this up
because these are the people that you
know these religious crazy Q Anon
conspiracy theory truth seeking the
cabal this the cabal that and then what
you find out it's actually the
Republican Party who are the ones that
are doing these crazy things no [__] are
you kidding me don't Hey listen I always
tell you to ease up on the facts that
you're gonna hurt these [__]
feelings that are in the chat these
moglodytes that are here hate launching
you're gonna really upset them with
facts that's that's some horrible stuff
hey I'm gonna speaking of [__] vile
sludge
um did you hear Pat Robertson finally
[__] kick the bucket I can't tell you
I can't tell you how excited I am this
morning I mean I gotta say what a beaut
I mean like talk about a gift to uh
right pride month right I mean the guys
is down there with Satan uh you know
just having his own butt flanked
barbecue that you think you think that
might be Pat Robinson's um punishment in
hell is that they'll slice his butt
cheeks Grill it and make him eat it like
on that like on like Hannibal Lecter
made Randy Orton's character eat his own
brain yeah yeah remember that yeah maybe
maybe they're gonna make it nice right
exactly I mean fried brain probably does
smell nice yeah I mean it probably I
mean it does I'm saying I can only
imagine especially if you're frying it
in like uh olive oil you know what I
mean right I'm trying I'm trying to get
this
don't imagine there'd probably be a high
kind of temperatures you don't want to
use olive you want to use like grape
seed oil or avocado oil they have a high
temperature uh cooking points a lot of
people are gonna give me [__] because
I'm running laps and pissing on Pat
Robinson's grade but guess what I don't
know the guy spends his whole life doing
the same thing on those who were
different so that guy
Jerry Falwell and Pat Robertson right
after 9 11.
UM this was years ago but this isn't the
only instance where they said this kind
of vile [__] out in the open this is
trumpism before trumpism was cool folks
listen what we saw on Tuesday as
terrible as it is
could be minuscule if in fact if in fact
God continues to lift the curtain and
allow
the enemies of America
to give us probably what we deserve well
Jerry that's my feeling I think we've
just seen the the anti-chamber to Terror
we haven't even begun to see what they
can do to the major population actually
ACLU the ACLU has got to take a lot of
blame for this oh yeah and I know I'll
hear from them for this but uh throwing
God off successfully with the help of
the federal court system throwing God
out of the Public Square out of the
schools uh the abortionists have got to
Bear some burden for this because God
will not be mocked and will be destroy
40 million little innocent babies we
make God man I I really believe that the
pagans and the abortionists and the
feminists and the gays and the lesbians
who are actively trying to make that an
alternative lifestyle the ACLU people
for the American way all of them who
tried to secularize America
I point the thing in their face and say
you helped this happen
what is the point that thing in their
face did you catch that yeah does he get
his dick out and point it in people's
faces because this is a finger that
could be construed as a thing
um that's Jerry Falwell Jr and [__] that
guy too I'll dance around on his [__]
grave as well [__] both of these
terrible terrible people I mean these
are the people that you know that want
uh that don't that don't see those in
the lgbtq plus Community as people right
they don't you know minorities oh
marginalized communities [__] no there
is only one group that is great and
that's the white man right and that's
exactly if you're white you're religious
you're God-fearing but again I'll bring
it back to something we've talked about
before is like
they want to blame
and use these people these marginalized
communities as a scapegoat to talk about
the sins of humanity right and if God
was now you know before Old Testament
God was you know fear uh inducing
omnipotent kind of person New Testament
God was like oh [__] I should be more
lenient and loving right if God truly
was loving and everyone was his children
then God would prevent these acts of
Terror and would prevent these these
horrible horrible uh events from
happening but religious people use that
as an excuse to say well the reason it
happened
is because because not only that but
they're like what they're saying is
these gay people are more powerful than
God
because God couldn't stop them from
doing whatever this sin or whatever it
is right like that's really what it
comes down to Marcy and ask here on
YouTube who's this old dinosaur this is
Jerry Falwell Jr uh he started Liberty
University and I don't know if you heard
of a Jerry Falwell junior or this is
Jerry Falwell excuse me yeah yeah it's
senior Jerry Falwell Jr is the one who
would have uh a young pool boy [__] his
wife while he watched
um and he would he would I mean he this
is we joke about these other people
being Cuts this guy alternative
Lifestyles that Jerry Falwell
right
listen if you listen if you want your
wife to do that with some and you get on
on that whatever if it's consensual I
don't give a [__] what you do in your
bed whatever the [__] you want to do but
don't be coming out and jamming down our
throat your [__] religious beliefs in
our government and our relationships
what we can and can't do who we can and
can't [__] love and how what love
[__] is and what it ain't you you
[__] like this old dinosaur
Marcia says here Jerry Falwell and Pat
Robertson perpetuated this stupid [__]
where they even this week this week they
[__] put their religions in schools
in Oklahoma with public money it's a
bunch of [__] but you know not only
that but out here out here in Glendale
right like literally 10 minute 10
minutes from where I am right now is
where they had this yeah and you want to
know who it was it was religious you
know it was religious right Patriot or
uh uh proud boys as well right you know
Andy no being like look at all these uh
left-wing extremists dude
was introduced and feel like hey look we
welcome this is something that should be
part of our right our school system in
the sense of of of of excel
that's kind of the thing and they're
like what do they do
they beat people up they also beat up a
homeless man who wasn't even involved he
was
and then the cops didn't do [__] about
it and the only people who were able to
protect him were the people that were
there
counter protesting these right-wing
extreme bigots
it's crazy it is [__] nuts uh Sandman
here points out because Jerry Falwell
said pagans the pagans which is why
don't you don't hear a lot anymore most
times like Communists and Marxist then
pagans you don't hear anymore and it's
funny because he also says what the [__]
and then you mean [__] but maybe you
don't want to play [__] yeah yeah
exactly does he know about pagans he
does know a lot about pagans I would
imagine saying man my guess is is that
Jerry Jerry Volvo is one because I bet
he gave Christmas presents I bet they
had Christmas trees oh man I bet they
had mistletoe in their house and all
kinds of [__] man [__]
um that doesn't have anything to do with
Jesus or the birth of Jesus or the Bible
yeah he's a paganie not to mention Jesus
wasn't born in December he was born like
in June
easy on your [__] facts you and your
facts damn it doing your thanks again oh
what the facts so um here's another
video which is uh another
um scummy moment well let's see do I
want to do oh
uh our friend Justin t Brown he um he
put out a video this morning this is
hilarious
um we've shown one of Elon before but I
want to show this one and that Justin
did this is great
you're kidding oh my God
that is unbelievable
it's true
oh my God
so thank you Justin uh for for that
great clip with Bernie there's one with
Elon have you seen the one with Elon
uh I don't think I've seen one with Elon
yeah where he's where elon's dead
um go go to Jeff oh no but but you know
it's not actually dead
well also I mean I don't know I gotta
say it's whether he was ever alive to
begin with because Elon Musk as we know
is an Android right he's a bit of a
skinwalker right he's got that he's got
that skin suit on yeah and he's the very
same way as uh as Ron DeSantis you know
well I'm gonna retweet this one this uh
Justin says have fun I'll show you this
one
you're kidding there it is oh my God
whatever you do whatever you do is true
whatever you do oh my God here's the
template whatever here's the template
fan from Justin so I'll read like don't
worry I've already uh chroma keyed this
area for you so you can easily yeah just
put in whatever the hell you want
um if you if you're if you're a good
enough editor you can just throw it in
you're good to go very very easy
so there's that one here's here's um you
remember the uh
oh I just want to say uh uh Boston Brian
now what are you doing I have no idea oh
my God I don't know what the hell that
was man uh no I saw Boston Brian was in
the chat I just want to say hello hello
hello
oh thanks for being here
let's see um uh here is Pat Robertson
you remember the uh earthquake in Haiti
where the [__] is I just lost it yeah of
a [__] I'm trying to find this
I know I know I know here's another one
um well I mean do I really have to show
it that much
um as far as Pat Robinson talking about
this is in 1992. ah maybe this is a good
one hell let's play this one let's play
this Pat Robertson clip if you're if
you're mad about me dancing on his grave
here you go maybe this will excite you a
little more Robertson and Lynn Martin
and more of your phone calls on Larry
King live and Tina Sinatra don't go away
[Music]
um
I don't know if you got that he's
whispering in a hot mic that guy was a
homo sure as you're alive we got a hot
mic here who is he talking about that
was a guest I have no idea I don't know
how weird there's the oh there's
actually hold on where's the where's the
uh
Pat Robertson clip it was the only one
we're like oh [__] that Robinson
actually said something that I might
agree with here
easy easy I know I know hold on hold on
let me see if I here's another one maybe
this uh maybe this will uh have some
good clips and let's listen
there's never been a civilization ever
in history that has embraced
homosexuality and uh uh has survived the
Bible says if any man will not work let
him not eat now that didn't say If any
man will not work let him go to the soup
kitchen and let the government pick up
the tab something happened a long time
ago in haitiated together and swore a
pact to the devil they said we will
serve you if you'll get us free from the
prince the people of color have to rise
up and overtake their oppressors and
then having gotten the whip panel if I
can use that term then to instruct their
white neighbors how to behave now that's
critical race Theory what is this mac
and cheese incredible black thing it is
a black thing Pat
whoa whoa whoa whoa wait a second is I
think that's one of one of the most
outrageous things I've ever heard Pat
Robinson say did he just ask
if mac and cheese was a black thing is
that what he said
yep yep yep what I'm sure I'm sure at
the same time he was also asking about
other stereotypes like fried chicken and
uh you know which which what's that
[__] um like z-list comedian
um Chrissy Mayer Chrissy mayor
Chrissy mayor [__] piece of garbage
hold on let me let me let me just pull
it up hold on because I feel like people
need to yeah yeah we'll we'll take a
look let me finish this uh Pat Robertson
then we'll go to the the the bile sludge
that mare is you could become a Muslim
then you could beat her what but in lieu
of that
you know this is just laughing okay
about the cheating he cheated on you
well he's a man okay there are a bunch
of people who were just bombs and if
these people are out drugging themselves
what I'm starting to do you've got a
couple of same-sex guys kissing you like
that well that makes me want to throw up
America if you want to bring the
Judgment of God on This Nation you just
keep this stuff up
oh so there's there's you a little bit
of uh Pat Robertson there and again if
you're mad at me for dancing on his
grave you can [__] off all the way all
the way off all the way off where's this
clip of Chrissy Mayer is it the second
one yeah the second one yeah
so when you hear someone like uh racist
piece of [__]
uh Rest in Piss
Pat Robertson
um
is that a black thing yeah when he says
[__] like that
and you hear other people talk about
Fried Chicken what's that mean mac and
cheese I don't know I mean they never
ate mac and cheese before
I have no idea what the right [__] or
he's like or he's like look I look I'm
I'm in my [__] G5 Jet and I don't
ever touch mac and cheese because that's
a poor person's food I mean it is
possible it is possible because I grew
up in the institution of white supremacy
I'm not [__] you it still exists
where I'm at I grew up in that
institution so it's possible that we
appropriated mac and cheese and I just
am not aware of it but I never I've
never heard that before until just now
that I imagine
I just don't well I personally don't
know because I never really grew up on
eating mac and cheese so I never well
again like it wasn't ever a thing that
we'd have mac and cheese in the house
all right it was always something else
yeah I would I would come home sometimes
from school and want a snack and I'd
make a whole blue box and eat that whole
[__] yeah the whole thing I just
never I never got into it I've only had
mac and cheese like a handful of times
in my life I think and most of them have
been somebody
I just never got into mac and cheese no
it's like I grew up in the Midwest and
it was pasta cheese what the [__] is
that the like it's just wasn't it just
wasn't a thing I got into
Jesus Christ I don't know man that's
very disappointing just like this is
disappointing I'm going to give you a
little context here I'm gonna put Big
Air quotes here comedian yeah she's a
comedian is this on Newsmax
would it be she's been on like um
Fox before I think but I'll give you a
little context so I called this [__]
and you're I'll say it out loud I call
her a [__] because she is a [__] [__]
okay she's a pile of [__] racist
bigoted trash is what she is all right
this Chrissy mayor I called her that on
a podcast her little troll Farm got
[__] mad at me for calling her a [__]
which she is you're gonna see it here
and if you don't like it well then
that's your [__] problem
but I call her the name and I still
stand by it to this day I'd stand by
calling her that that's what she is
now they got mad and they her little
[__] incel troll Farm doxed me so
much so that they were pulling pictures
of my children off someone's Facebook
page and posting them on Twitter telling
me I need to apologize or they're gonna
keep posting pictures and threatening my
family including my children yeah that
was pretty [__] up and I told them
guess what I told him I told him to [__]
oh actually I didn't say anything I'm
not gonna apologize to this [__]
piece of trash [__] you this [__] this
[__] can can live the life of Pat
Robertson if you know what I mean I
don't give a [__] about her and she's a
[__] vile piece of trash let me show
you this clip this is from one last week
on Newsmax this isn't this is in 1992 of
Pat Robertson talking about a great year
of
2023. and let's listen to her joke about
Fried Chicken
it's pretty ridiculous uh to to just
assume that Chick-fil-A I mean
you know I'm hesitant to make a fried
chicken joke but they said chicken I
don't know how much more inclusive we
can get here
does she think that's a joke
here's the thing is that this is this is
the stupid thing where you put comedian
as your title like her Joe Rogan or
anyone else and then they start making
jokes about stuff like oh what are you
getting upset about it's just a joke
it's just a joke haha I'm a comedian
like all right well I mean you had the
freedom to be a bigot on Newsmax
you have the freedom to be a [__]
vile piece of sludge on TV if you want
that's cool well you know that's
whatever you want to do when we're going
to call it out and say that yeah not
only is it not funny it's [__] racist
as [__] yeah and you also have to
remember that anyone who is uh of of the
mindset oh don't be so sensitive or this
or that especially when they're making a
joke that [__] punches down right and
also and also the delivery let's let I
mean like even the mechanics of the
Joker like it's so [__] hard to
follow because you even yourself
hesitate you're like oh I'm hesitant to
to say this but uh uh how inclusive can
they be there's fried chicken that's not
a joke that's you making a racist
observation that's a stereotype and then
trying to it says I'm a comedian so take
everything I say as a joke and it's like
no you're just a [__] bigot and this
isn't the first time that she's tried
something no hell no some stupid joke
well let me show you the thread here
if you're if you're mad that I called
her a [__] and I still call her a [__]
because she is
um here's the thread here's the original
poster that was Dave Rubin laughing in
the background she gives a link to Media
Matters here and then the same account
says muting too many races and
transphobes in my mentions because I
know what this piece of [__] does she
gets her stupid [__] incel troll farm
and they come attack accounts they
attacked they attacked some of our
[__] listeners on Twitter because
they were like hey shut the [__] up or
whatever when they were posting pictures
of my children that's right this [__]
piece of sludge my guess is I bet
without a doubt that this piece of
sludge directed her in cell Farm to go
out and grab pictures of my children my
underage children post them on Twitter
to get me to apologize to her so much so
that the stupid [__] messaged me on a
thread asking me to follow her so she
could DM me
[__] out of here that [__] now so I just
want to point that out and there's also
there's also I just want to quickly go
if you click on the third link that I
sent you right the other one that
actually was posted she posted this she
posted this now I don't know if you guys
remember this or if you ever saw this
but there's a video that Chrissy Mayer
posted when Black Panther wakanda
forever came out okay
now this is you this is yeah this is uh
this is her yeah
there is a funny part in it though I
mean I remember this video now there is
a funny part in it right come on I think
I'll point it out watch this watch this
she's going to the theater it's like
it's like eight o'clock in the morning
right this is their very first it's like
before it's it's before noon like the
earliest matinee no one goes to your
citizen discount time right right watch
watch as she tries to go in the theater
that's the funny part yeah yeah so
excited to see wakanda forever here at
White Plains
I know okay do you notice what the door
says
maybe she has a hard time
I mean she's a dumb [__] so I wouldn't
be surprised if she couldn't read she's
a stupid stupid stupid [__] now
she she obviously makes the white joke
White Plains haha black panther
now watch as she tries to go in the exit
only I feel the same way
what the hell
oh Elon you piece of [__] let's see if
we can get it
the video is all [__] up
oh Reef refresh it don't just play it
all the way refresh the page damn it
don't stop it God damn it this is what
happens when you try to stop and
commentate on what no you know what you
know what it is this is [__] Twitter
man
this is Twitter Twitter's [__]
getting in the trash can
so excited to see will come to Forever
White
I feel the same way oh oh yeah that one
said it too
it's like they're already sending me a
message
I don't know I mean it's not so much to
send you a message as you're a [__]
dumbass anyway the point that she tries
to make yes
no one is there but it's also because
she went in the [__] morning and
tried to approve a point and not only
that but even on the ticket stub they
show the ticket stub and it also shows
the time on the ticket stuff which is
you know typically people will go see
this movie I think it was like opening
day or whatever that it was like
Thursday or Friday morning and she went
to go see it when normally
you know people have work and school and
things like that and so she instead of
going to see it at night right or in the
evening when everyone else would see it
whenever would be [__] packed when
people are available she thought that
she could go in the morning and then she
showed the ticket on the on the video
and everyone's like you [__] idiot
like if you're gonna make this if you're
trying to create this narrative that no
one's there do not tell us what time you
were there right right yeah don't tell
us that it's the show that no one's
probably gonna go see anyways you mean
the one that set a box office record you
mean the one that including myself
including myself as someone from the
Latino community that watch and I was
like oh man this [__] movie is great
because there's that kind of forever was
great it was yeah it was amazing I'll
tell you that I think wakanda forever
was better than the Little Mermaid but
it's the same it's the same people that
are mad that there's a that there's a
Black Panther movie it's saying people
like huh Ariel's black that that mermaid
that Fantasy character if I got here
what's this other video you sent me here
oh this one is Kailyn she sent me so if
you give context you got to read the
Tweet above
the Tweet oh so she said this is a song
that was written if I read it correctly
okay so so um Ryan Karim here come on
God damn it this is what what the [__]
this is from July 27 2022. what rabbit
hole do we are we in here she sent me
this tweet said they even made it now
former cop spiritual advisor and
Christian mega church leader Ted Haggard
faces allegations of inappropriate
touching of young men this seems to be a
pattern
um with these church leaders not with
drag queens and she says this they even
made a song about him give it a chance
all the way through okay well let's
let's give it a shot are we gonna get
copyright for this
Haggard is completely heterosexual
[Music]
who stumbled from the path or you might
even say stagger
he was one in a million or more aptly
one in ten
some folks say he put the man in
oh man
he preached the gospel message of
intolerance and self-loathing
traveled on his Wayward way betraying
his betrothing
it was the soul of piety and no one
doubted him until he hired a gigolo and
used a suit in him
so he probably went to counseling and
then three weeks later he's born again
again
[Music]
he telephoned the White House for a
weekly consultation
saying here
of all the pending legislation
marriage is a covenant between a man and
wife and homosexuals will cry forever in
the afterlife
some other things he'd later disavowed
but he's putting it all behind him now
what does Leviticus have to say yeah
what does it say about being gay to lie
with man is an Abomination like cursing
your parents trimming your beard
planting wheat and barley in the same
Furrow eating pork wearing polyester and
Mass
and what did Jesus have to say yeah what
did he say about being gay well nothing
now Ted's a little Haggard but he's
thankful for the schism
[Music]
[Applause]
you're right but wait for it
and you might find it hard to swallow
and it turns out that he just got caught
with a male prostitute again no kidding
I mean hey Ted what do what you want to
do man yeah just stop telling other
[__] what to do exactly stay
out of their bodies stay out of their
home stay out of their lives do your own
thing
you know remember you know do not do not
throw stones in Glass Houses my friend
do not throw stones because you're gonna
[__] crash crash crumble and destroy
your own home oh man look someone's
gonna find out like Ethan Schmidt turns
out that that dude's [__] rolling
through grinder these days well hey man
hey when you when you're you know
running around trying to um do the
conversion therapy by Smashing up Pride
displays and threatening to kill gay
people you know a lot of people were
saying though that it could be a little
more Sinister what Ethan Schmidt if for
everyone he doesn't know right yeah yeah
Ethan Schmidt is the Kerry Lake
supporter
yeah he's the Albuquerque he actually is
the one that helped us develop the alpha
cuck from a video where he got cut by
some uh he's like a teenager that was
asking for a position yeah skinny little
kid outside of a retail store and and
Ethan Schmidt thought it was a good idea
to approach him and this kid [__] ate
his lunch the point is his English
Schmidt goes around smashing up private
states he goes in like PetSmart and
Target and all these stores and he
[__] harasses the employees and the
customers about just stay on the store
[__] you don't like the rainbows
you're scared of the rainbows stay out
of the store [__] don't then you
might just stay in your own home because
they're right rainbows that occur in the
sky in nature it's kind of crazy it's
crazy I know I mean you know science and
[__] but if he's so afraid of rainbows
it's like maybe he should just stay in
his mom's basement you know man he
should he should but a lot of people are
saying the reason why he was on Grinders
because he was targeting people right
right he would like entrap these people
but a lot of people are saying nope new
new new new there's a there's a part of
me that's like oh yeah he could totally
do that but I would imagine that he
would get his [__] ass beat right and
again any one of these again go on
grinder if you want to get on Grindr no
big deal man just don't judge others
right just stop making [__] videos
like you're hunting these same
[__] that you're trying to [__]
on Grindr stop doing that and stop going
into [__] retail stores and harassing
customers and employees because you're
terrified and scared of rainbows
um speaking of
um I'm gonna move here real quick
because there's a video
Ron's posted on Twitter Marjorie Taylor
green apparently she's seen the
bereavement document if you're unaware
if you're unaware what the Republican
lie is now you know the the transactions
China thing that didn't [__] work the
hunter buying laptop that [__] didn't
work did you hear her recently did you
hear that she she was at a she said that
she had watched all of it January six
footage yep which is in 140 000 hours
yeah
one single person like a thousand years
to watch us it was like [__]
a year and a half straight yeah end to
end with no sleep 24 hours a day 24
hours a day 540 some days just scrub
through all the data and that's not even
that she's watching hey that's straight
payback that's not even scrubbing
telling you stop with your facts okay
stop stop it stop it look you're gonna
look you're you're banging up their
whole [__] narrative when you bring
out the facts and lay them out on the
table Jazz you do you have any idea do
you have any idea how hard it is going
to be for them to win next year if you
just keep [__] laying out facts out
there you know about any I'm sorry but
look call me a faxist right I practice
fascism that hey there you go [__]
tweet that [__] we said [__] right later
than fascism there you go that's it
that's it well here's a little bit of
fascism it definitely doesn't have facts
in it apparently listen to what this
dumb [__] says in front of a microphone
he told the informant that he has two
pieces of evidence showing proof of
payment to Hunter and specifically Joe
Biden
okay so where is it where's the evidence
then yeah if he has them where are they
oh that's right
they don't exist now this is the barisma
thing okay let me let me just give a
quick synopsis of this so we can move on
past this and they can go to like
Benghazi I'm sure that's what the next
thing is right because they like just
keep going back in time further and
further and further I bet I bet
eventually they're gonna like bring
Monica Lewinsky into
um these weaponization hearings yeah and
talk about
um the [__] that she gave Bill
Clinton at the end of his second term
I'm just saying that that's probably how
far back they're gonna go here they're
gonna I mean it's it's gonna somehow
it's gonna be Biden's fault I mean we're
right
it used to be Obama you remember when it
was like thanks Obama yeah remember when
you remember what the good old days they
tried that and then Obama was like yeah
look I'm gonna goof on myself because I
I have empathy and I know yeah it's the
cookie one it wouldn't fit in the middle
yeah
but here's the bereavement thing okay so
when Joe Biden was vice versa President
right they had this big master plan that
he would be president one day and he
would beat Donald Trump after Donald
Trump uh committed a violent
Insurrection to try to overthrow the
government but Joe Biden still won Joe
Biden is so sleepy and so dementia
ridden but he has such foresight right
he has such foresight of these things
even though he's dementia ridden uh he
had the foresight
um when he was vice president to go over
to Ukraine and tell Ukraine and pressure
Ukraine to get rid of prosecutors who
were not listen to me were not
Prosecuting crimes that barisma may have
been committing okay are you following
me barisma which is the company that
Hunter Biden Joe Biden's son sat on the
board of okay you got it
he went over there and he pressured
Ukraine to get rid of the prosecutor who
would not prosecute barisma which his
son worked for that is what Joe Biden
did it's in real time you can see the
reporting no one paid attention to it at
the time because everyone's like yeah
that's what you should do right is make
sure to prosecute companies that are
[__] corrupt and you should get rid
of prosecutors who aren't Prosecuting
corrupt companies because they're
[__] corrupt we should do that and
the you and it was only us the United
States
um backing this pilot or or this wanting
this policy change from Ukraine with
this prosecutor from the UE and the
reason why is because these crimes are
having you know downward effect
as it were
to the UE and they wanted them
prosecuted they wanted them to be
investigated because it was kind of like
out in the open but hunter Biden served
on the board of barisma okay the company
that Joe Biden went over there and said
if you don't you got to get rid of the
prosecutor who won't prosecute the
[__] company
that my son sits on the board of and the
reason why Joe Biden did that is because
Joe Biden was the vice president he was
in the Convoy that went to represent the
United States to send the president at
the time Barack Obama's policy and what
his message was on this particular issue
with this prosecutor it's not [__]
complicated to go back and look at the
reports at the time and understand that
the mainstream media the cabal wasn't
lying because one of these days they
were gonna use Hunter Biden as some sort
of tool to make Joe Biden president or
something you [__] idiots were were
good we're good but we are not near that
good if we were near that good this
[__] idiot would be nowhere near
Congress okay yeah yeah if we were
really that good this [__] idiot
would not be standing in front of these
Minds I mean the only reason that she is
at the position she's at is because the
first time she ran for Congress is her
opponent was literally threatened doxed
by other q a on crazy conspiracy people
from the right you know so this idea is
like oh the violence and we're so we're
victims and this and that no no no no
her supporters the crazy deranged
delusional Q Anon you know believing
truth seeking people that thought that
Donald Trump was going to be [__]
reinstated as president in March and
then April and then September and blah
blah all these other dates these are the
same people that threatened her opponent
who was running in her Georgia District
so it that's the only reason that she's
actually in her position and the second
time was because you know he's [__]
crazy enough was able to fundraise money
and use Trump's name it's it's insane
right
it's very insane but I do want to point
out one thing I sent you just quickly a
tweet from uh from from our boy Benji
Johnson the guy who sounds like a
[__] dog
he had a tweet his name sounds like a
dog he sounds like
yo guys I I'm gone we're gonna go shoot
some uh beer and it's gonna be great
and whatever so I actually you know it's
okay you're you're in the Haggard you're
in the Haggard group actually you know
what so he released a video the other
day for context so for people to know
this uh Benny or as I call it call him
Benji uh Benji bought a bunch of Bud
Light he made a video the other day and
he went to a gun range and he set up the
beer and and shot it all right ooh he's
so tough so so then I was like oh
uh what the whole what the what why are
you buying beer right and he goes oh
well I got this you know he says in the
video I got this 15 rebate okay so he
claimed with the rebate paid for the end
he said ammunition he said the rebate
paid for the beer and also the
ammunition so I was like oh I'm curious
about this is why Google Bud Light
rebate so I look it up and it says yeah
it's 15 bucks however you're only
limited to one purchase so that means
that he would have to go through on
possibly multiple different purchases
one case at a time up to the 15 value
now I highly doubt that he that he did
that well in that in the one video he
had all of them in one yeah
120 beers something like that which I
mean hey it could be that he [__]
again this is all fake anyways right all
this [__] is fake like he really
doesn't believe that Bud Light he's not
gonna submit a rebate you have to go
online and submit your you have to
submit for your receipt and then you
wait like two months right and then you
get the fifteen dollars back I highly
doubt that he ever submitted or was
planning to
so he got all [__] up and he was like
oh Bud Light you know anyway so I saw
this post today because everyone's
talking about I saw I saw this dude I
saw this and he and he's upset right
because this is this is the same logic
that there's like why is no one ever at
the
boys there never anyone wearing a Joe
Biden Harris hat like you never see
anybody wearing the the gear of the of
the president of the United States but
the vice president and it's like because
we're not a cult
I mean that's that's a good one we're
not a cult so so he says in this tweet
he says Joe Biden has been running
for president for two months in that
time zero campaign rallies zero events
with running mate because they're the
president vice president you Demi
um fell on face blamed sandback no he
tripped over a sandbag and he bought
himself and he was skipping afterwards
at the White House he came back yeah
indicted political opponents on fake
charges dude Joe Biden is not the
Manhattan D.A yeah what the [__] is this
guy
Joe Biden is not running the court the
in in the the court system in Manhattan
he's not running the court system in
Georgia in other states for RICO case
he's also not running the investigation
and looming indictments
for the Mar-A-Lago documents case and
then also the Jan 6 case right so you
know he's like oh he's he's and this is
again this is the same type of argument
where somebody says this guy is so
sleepy he's an incompetent senile man
that's sleeping on a lazy boy in a
basement but at the same time he's also
out maneuvering every single Republican
representative who tried to [__] own
him when it came to the debt limit deal
and then guess what he [__] owned
them and he was like look I'm not
backing on any of these things I'm not
going to cut Social Security I'm not
going to cut Medicare and guess what
you're gonna [__] agree to it and
vote to it and now Kevin McCarthy has to
pay the consequences for
cooking to Joe Biden because now
everyone I don't know if you saw the two
days ago they stopped a couple different
uh it was like process bills that were
on the floor and they did not allow them
to to pass through right right yeah
today you got Matt Gates you've got
Lauren bobert all of these people are
beginning to say no no we're going to
hold strong and we're not going to let
any of this stuff pass through that
would be proposed by Republicans and
it's becoming you know and now it's a
countdown how many days does Kevin
McCarthy have left as Speaker of the
House before somebody says uh you know
what can we call a vote on the floor for
a new Speaker of the House right you've
got Steve Bannon saying that Keem
Jeffries and Joe Biden are [__] the
man right and owned Kevin McCarthy and
Kevin McCarthy and I quote is a [__]
yeah Kevin McCarthy a [__] Steve Bannon
yeah well so so I'm gonna go back to
this just for a second because let's
let's suppose that Benny would be
writing a tweet about um his orange
Mussolini Jesus because he's a trump
simp right
um and let's say he was writing a tweet
about uh Joe but Donald Trump here
instead of Joe Biden and let's say
because how many campaign rallies has
Trump canceled because he couldn't guy
their crowd how many how many running
mates how many running mates does Donald
Trump have does he have a running mate I
mean his running mate from last time
announced and said that Donald Trump
should never be president again and he
chose the Constitution over Donald Trump
that's kind of funny
um also he falls on his face every
[__] day when he's admitting the
crimes on true social right and he
actually has been indicted on criminal
charges and it looks like he's going to
receive criminal charges like three
maybe four other
um jurisdictions before it's all not
only that but he was also found liable
for you know I mean he did he raped
sexual assault Carol but he got found
liable for sexual assault
and then not only that but then he
doubled down and now he's getting sued
again well of course he is ah this guy
Benny you [__] suck instead of your
Tweet
um
so let's uh you know what speaking of
presidential candidates I gotta show I
gotta show you this this is [__]
hilarious
um I I can't tell you how irrelevant
Mike Pence is but he doesn't even know
how irrelevant he is but this is this
clip here is uh a direct representation
of the two-tier justice system that Maga
has been bitching about ever since Trump
was indicted I've got something for you
after that okay good so so they when
Trump was uh it was suspected that the
Manhattan die was going to indict Trump
um everyone's like two-tier justices
some two-tier justice system and I said
from the get-go yes there is a two-tier
justice system and the reason why you're
pissed off is because your tear is not
protecting Donald Trump anymore the the
upper tier that normally protects rich
white men is not protecting Donald Trump
anymore that's why you're [__] pissed
off now here is Mike Pence the saltine
candy it here not not The Manchurian
Candidate the saltine candidate
um describing in great detail the
two-tier death system that their man
that is not protecting Donald Trump
listen I think now more than ever we
ought to be finding ways we could
actually come together and this kind of
this kind of action by the Department of
Justice I think would only fuel uh
further division in the country and let
me also call [__] Justice I think
would also send a terrible message to
The Wider world
I mean we're the we're the emblem of
democracy we're the symbol of Justice in
the world
there's a serious matter which has
already happened once in New York I mean
dieting a former president of the United
States sends a terrible message to the
world I hope don't cry doj thinks better
of it and resolves these issues without
an indictment sir I just want to clarify
this is what you're saying is that if
they believe he committed a crime they
should not go forward with an indictment
you just talked before about no
committing to the rule of law I just
don't know okay
but with regard to the unique
circumstances here
look I
those classified I had no business
having classified documents in my
residence okay and I took full
responsibility for it did you President
Biden had no business having him in his
residence from when he was vice
president as well I think he took full
responsibility yeah yeah just shy of
saying he also took full responsibility
let's keep listening and the same with
former president Trump nope totally
different but I I would just hope that
there would be a way for them to move
forward without the dramatic and drastic
and divisive step and there it is there
it is that's it that's it that's the
two-tier justice system that they're mad
that their tier is no longer going to
protect him because here's the rep folks
if they'll go after Donald Trump and
indict Donald Trump they'll indict Mike
Pence do you want to know why this is
the dumbest argument ever well I mean
they're because the only shot he has at
being the president anything that's
above like one two three percent in the
polls
is if Donald Trump is [__] indicted
and actually has to uh you know yeah but
move himself from the race right but I
actually think but I actually think that
when Donald Trump gets indicted like I
said in the a block when he gets
indicted you know you've been in these
Twitter spaces man I know it's gonna
turn these these uh these really kind of
half-assed DeSantis supporters and
they're gonna it's gonna turn that
they're gonna be like yeah Trump yeah
Trump because what is DeSantis going to
do is DeSantis going to land punches on
him no no I mean the closest thing he
has is the uh is the uh human
trafficking case that's against him for
sending people yeah but here's the thing
though is that but you can't what is
Santa's gonna say is well the doj is no
longer woke because they're Prosecuting
my political opponent Donald Trump they
put themselves in this position man and
then you have Chris Christie like the
the opposite of [__] DeSantis right
and Chris Christie's totally gonna punch
on Donald Trump about this oh my God
he's gonna just be pounding him and
that's gonna make it to where Chris
Christie loses because Chris Christie is
going to operate in the space that that
Mike Pence is not where he's like I hate
Donald Trump Donald Trump shouldn't be
president but he shouldn't go to prison
Chris Christian's like [__] yeah I've
seen that [__] to prison this is
a Maga cult is gonna take that
Republican primary yeah sure right no
that's I mean and the reason I say that
is because I'm like look if you
eliminate one person from the actual
running not to say that it really will
but if you do like that's the only shot
they have right and so when he's like oh
well you know it's like man you should
be [__] going after this and that he
should be charged and hold your [__]
position because then you won't be this
[__] two-faced cook that even when
people were like hey Mike Pence you're
like man I love these people these
people are gonna vote for me and it's
like no they're not because also when
you look at the candidates
uh you have Nikki Haley she was done as
soon as Donald Trump released a video of
her saying I'm not gonna run if Donald
Trump runs Tim Scott not an actual
threat to Donald Trump because who
Tim Scott who again uh nobody knows
really anything about the the only thing
we really know is that he's uh he was 46
when he lost his virginity okay no
judgment 57 now so he's had 11 years to
really get that in hey well well here's
the other thing too is Tim Scott has 20
million dollars that he's going to spend
to hurt DeSantis that's the No No
totally totally but the other thing too
is like I feel like so you've got you've
got Nikki Haley already done Tim Scott
skeletons are going to come out of that
closet he's going to wish never came out
you've got uh Chris Christie who is now
going to there's stuff that's going to
be coming out against him for the very
fact that he was like I'll literally
almost died because Trump gave me covid
because we were practicing for the 2020
debate you know when Christy was done
when Trump sent that [__] that that
video of making fun of him being fat
that's it well it wasn't even the video
called was it the video or the a photo
that he posted last year where he was at
the late night buff it was someone that
was had the same like body structure as
Chris Christie and he's like Chris
Christie 11 p.m at the whatever Buffet
right right and then of course this
video came out right and then you then
you've got uh Rhonda Santos who's an
Android has no chance then you got vivec
who we know is a [__] Trump plant and
then you've got uh then then you've got
Donald Trump right those are the
candidates maybe someone else will will
kind of rise up through the bottom to be
like I'm also running but no chance
who's this guy from like uh is it North
Dakota who's this guy I don't know who
the [__] is that guy you you said that
you said yesterday there was someone
from North Dakota I have no idea North
Dakota look I don't even know anyone who
like who's the I don't even know who the
people are from North Dakota that are
Representatives or Senators I'm just I'm
telling you what that what the news is I
mean it's it's almost as it's almost as
laughable as Marianne Williamson
challenging Joe Biden and the Democratic
said yeah I mean she's she's still
begging to get on a Twitter space with
Elon Musk
DM me and Gabe we can probably set
something up with Mario oh yeah I
guarantee we probably could have been I
bet Mario oh [__] yeah especially if I'm
in there bashing you Mario would
definitely probably let us have that
space because I'm telling you uh last
night in that space speaking of spaces
before we go on to um uh shitty legal
takes with Helena Haba uh before we wrap
up your uh about the Trump coming
indictments possibly
um last night at Twitter space because I
was listening it's Wednesday I had
karaoke so they were all right but I I
couldn't speak but I was listening to
you most of the time uh when you're
schooling these people on like how media
works it was hilarious I was like you've
got mainstream traditional old media and
you've got new media on the internet and
everyone and I will say yesterday yeah
this is this is the first time I've ever
been able to speak for minutes on end
without anyone interrupting me because
they're like oh [__] we have no idea how
they had no clue and how they feed into
other other mediums and platforms what's
hilarious is there was people on this in
this space that were invited to be like
experts on Tucker Carlson and media and
him moving their [__] conversation so
it was so well and I I had to I had to
go before you finished it up yeah but
but it's crazy that they they were like
enamored by like oh well we didn't even
think about it like that like how could
you not see I mean these things aren't
hard to see they're easy to see just
well yeah they're like a little bit they
were like oh what uh because for anyone
who doesn't know Tucker Carlson released
his first episode on Twitter Tucker on
Twitter uh which now it sounds
for a preaching contract but in this
video he talks about a bunch of stuff
it's a bunch of Click bait like very uh
you know provocateur you know conspiracy
talks about aliens and [__] they got up
on a tangent for like 30 minutes about
aliens and they're like do you believe
in dailies and I was like look man I
can't prove that aliens exist and they
don't exist so for that right whatever
the hood exists like you said who the
[__] would want to come here and Jack
with us anyways yeah like we got all
kinds of problems and any problems no
one else in the universe wants like do
you think that people want like do you
think that Jesus Christ intelligent life
formers want to come to this planet and
look at it like the only thing is if
they wanted to use this as like a like a
you know kind of in The Matrix where
it's like we're a batter we're an energy
source but other than that like they
could easily do these things without us
yeah I'm sure if there's if they're
gonna tell me
Well if there is other intelligent life
out there I'm sure there's planets that
they could raid that are much better
than ours yeah yeah way better than
hours easily but but the thing is about
the space is that it was it was so
[__] weird because a lot of these
people even if they're right left Center
whatever whatever on the ideological
spectrum that they are in this space a
lot of them are Elon sense and the
reason why is because they want to build
their Twitter account like it's this
desire to have hundreds of thousands of
followers and at one point I guess maybe
I was like oh I want to have as many
followers I can on Twitter but I stopped
giving a [__] about six or eight months
ago I really did I stopped giving you
[__] because I'm like Jesus Christ what
does it really mean to have 300 300 000
people that see you say something on
Twitter then what then what the then
what the [__] like what then what so
what they sell me reply to someone what
the who gives a [__] right so I'd stop
caring about that as much like how many
right and it's just like I'm just gonna
have uh quality and I I like to talk not
to type so that's why we have the show
yeah yeah but I found it fascinating
fascinating
that these people couldn't even
understand simple little truths and
facts about how media Works they were
like whoa because they're like oh the
mainstream media is dead and you're like
no not really technically all the
stories that you guys are talking about
in these spaces
are and you Pucket [__] put
mainstream media articles up in the
[__] Nest to prove your point like
how don't you know this how don't you
know that the mainstream media a lot of
times is the beginning
of the [__] feedback right and I was
like I had and so I had to explain I was
like you've got mainstream media feeds
into this New Media which could be you
know YouTube shorts and this and that
they also tried to [__] they're like
oh Twitter's gonna be this uh media
Network and I was like no that's not and
then this one guy uh Dr Danish was like
oh no no what's gonna be a doctor of by
the way I think I think it's like a
neuro neurosurgeon or something like
that I I don't I don't know something
like that but would you want that guy
working on your [__] brain oh no not
at all I mean the way that he was like
he was like and then he tried to argue
that Elon Musk created Twitter spaces at
one point and I was like what yeah he
was like oh and what happened to the
clubhouse the original audio space
version right that's that's that's where
Twitter right kind of that they launched
spaces to kind of see if they could
compete the spaces was it's garbage now
but it was way worse when it first
started it was and so that's the thing
and so what they did is they copied it
and they're like we're gonna add this
feature because that's all it is it's a
feature on an existing app for people to
communicate with we'll take it from the
text format to an audio format and he
was like oh man we'll change they'll
change the behavior and I'm like look
I'm gonna put on my product designer and
Engineering hat right now because that's
my expertise in background and I can
tell you right now that what you're
trying to argue he was like well people
can go from that to watching long-form
video because look at what YouTube did
they had uh they had shorts and look
what Instagram had they realize I was
like yeah you're taking long format and
you're shrinking it down to short
formats right to then direct people back
to Long format not the opposite Twitter
and I was like Twitter is like the
living embodiment of ADHD and [__]
eavesdropping that's what it is so well
the other thing too you'd be able to
accomplish this on that platform the
other thing too is there's no guide
right there's no like there's no there's
no place that you can go you'll get
content I mean you can search topics you
can search words right and you can go
down a timeline whether you're in a
Lobby or someone else's timeline but
it's literally an archive is what it is
it's just a timeline archive so it's not
it's not a movie library right it's not
a library it's a [__] archive type of
your dumb [__] that you type out or
you post a picture a meme or video so
there's no organization of it you can't
go like I want to see documentaries
about dildos right nope I I just wanted
to make sure that we had zero days
yeah but all Twitter is is really it's
it's just a search engine right the
ability to post on it because right but
it's not us but it's right but photos
but there's no organization like you
can't it's not like Netflix or like you
know I want to see a comedy so I'll go
to I'll go to comedy movies and then
they have them kind of in in a different
set you know maybe it's like comedies
that you would enjoy based on your prior
history like that's not what Twitter's
algorithm does at all yeah it doesn't do
that and they're not changing it they
haven't listened to me they haven't
changed Twitter spaces since Elon took
over yep so as and so and so it all got
started because everyone's like oh my
God New Media like this is totally gonna
break old traditional news mainstream
media and I was like no it's not because
here's the thing guys as we've said on
the show before these are Impressions
this is people scrolling by they don't
have to stop and look at it it's at
least two seconds on a video of you and
everyone's like whoa whoa what what and
and the funny part about it is the I
after the after the the space ended I
looked at these interactions that were
on
on the thread right like tag with me and
tag with Mario and whoever else was
speaking
and everyone's like I don't agree with
this guy's politics but he makes a very
good point about the views and
Impressions it is really messed up it
doesn't make any sense and I was like no
it makes perfect sense I don't know I
know no no I mean like when well right
now right but well but they're confused
right this is their confusion because
they think everything Elon does is great
right and then one point I'm really
upset this one guy Dennis came in he's
like Don't Call Him a liar and I was
like he's alive he's alive he's a liar
he's [__] lying like I can call him
liar because he's lying and just because
you don't want me to call him liar and
it hurts your feelings doesn't mean he's
not what do you want from me speaking of
liars let's uh go to someone called her
someone called her Haba dabba do on
everything
um this is Elena habit we we've done a
couple videos where there's shitty legal
takes I got this I gotta say I don't
know who her like hair stylist is but
every time I see her it's either short
hair medium or long hair within days of
each other and I know my hair doesn't
grow that fast well that's gender
reaffirming um stuff like extensions
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay I
mean I'm just want to point that out
here is and I wonder if they sell those
at Target the extensions they probably
do it's in the same way I don't know I I
don't know if they sell extension beer
and the dildos and oh really yeah yeah
yeah is the Lube in that same it is it
is is it okay well I'm just making sure
okay here's her take on how prosecutors
um prosecute criminals uh Mark Meadows
comes out okay and or it comes out that
Mark Meadows is actually working with
the prosecution to potentially get a
plea deal to plead guilty to certain
things to help the prosecution against
Donald Trump what that he has immunity
that's what we're hearing um it's
obviously news to me I just learned it
with you
um but yeah that's what we're hearing is
that he was granted immunity so
effectively he would be a key witness
against the president
um and give testimony in opposition of
him which as we've seen honestly Carl
time and time again this is what they
did to Alan weisselberg in the D.A case
in New York this is what they do time
and again to anybody that is he was
convicted to uh the Trump World
president Trump because they have
nothing so they have to squeeze people
scare people and intimidate them into uh
testifying and and in the direction that
they want
um it's very disturbing um that's right
I like the truth is that what you're
saying this is what prosecutor this is
like their entire job she not know that
where did she [__] go to law school
at where did she go to law school she
might have gone to the same law school
as uh as as uh [__]
what's her name the fart one from
Colorado oh Jenna Ellis yeah that's the
one Jenna Ellis I mean oh good old
janellis let's see Alina Haba law school
because I know I've looked uh Widener
wait hold on let's see let's see let me
show weidener University commonwealth
law school in 2010. okay that's where
she got her JD I don't know that school
at all I don't know it might be a good
one it might be a good one but she
didn't get a she didn't learn a [__]
thing while she was there it's clear uh
let's see Google is Widener Commonwealth
a good law school it's ranked number one
in the nation for employment outcomes by
pre-law magazine earned an a rating for
our environmental law program which
she's not doing chosen as a top loss
over government careers inside his top
law school so it seems like it could be
good I don't know hey you know what I
mean it might be the one that you uh go
to get really shitty legal takes do you
want to see a really shitty uh true
social ad oh yeah hilarious so I went to
check I was and I was like
checking every [__] minute for
Grandpa poopy pants over last night he
got real real upset yeah well I couldn't
I can't set notifications for him for
whatever reason I don't know why it's
probably you probably have like a
guardian angel looking over your
shoulder I don't like hey dude don't I
don't know right don't do it yeah but
when I went over there to look I went to
his feed and the funniest thing I found
was this ad this is a real [__] ad
that I screenshot from True social
they're great they're quality high
quality ads over there look at this look
at that [__] man not only not only is
this thing I mean that's horrible
horrible design look at the margins on
the art here look at that who the [__]
looks it's obvious their target audience
is like
a 70 year old white dude right okay so
this this is the ad so I don't know do
you think they're paying money or he's
just like these are just like um uh just
ads to make it look like they have ads I
mean these are the ads to make it look
like they have ads this is somebody
who's in like Ms paint and they're just
like writing the text and they're like
yeah that's good enough you know like
he's he's probably right like look at
this it's all like it looks like Trump
made it well yeah it's like he's Trump
innocent why are these words capitalized
I did no idea they didn't even they
didn't even put Trump they're on there
or like me there's a part of me did you
click through this ad or no no no I
didn't click through it sometimes you
gotta click through do you see how crazy
uh sign up I screenshot it went straight
to Twitter it was like look at what I
found I thought I found gold most kills
didn't agree what you see
is I wouldn't be surprised if I can
encounter this ad right now I'm going on
my phone uh if you if you encounter
these ads yeah and I would I wouldn't be
surprised like one mine right now says
one half cup of this
before bed in parentheses can melt your
belly fat like never before what the
[__] oh that's a real one yeah but look
uh the way that I look at this is this
could possibly be his if you didn't
click through then we don't know but the
way that Trump's
um Pages work on for any anything you
interact with take this poll do this
thing right it all sounds like oh we'll
send you this thing there's a there's a
monetary value that you have to pay into
so each of these polls are like do you
think Trump will win the 2024 election
let us know now and then you answer the
poll and then it goes now pay us and
you're like wait wait and it's like I
mean donate donate the money and it's
like that's
and people fall for it well here's so so
people listening to the audio version
here's what the ad says now it looks
like [__] like Gabe said it looks like
it's [__] Ms paint like this is like
default blue color this is like
hyperlink blue color right now is [__] I
mean reward is capitalized right here
here's here's what it says is Trump
innocent question mark please
participate in our poll and as a thank
you we will send you a free gift meaning
they're wanting an email address and an
address there's a there's a big problem
here uh no comma right
so and well also using an ampersand I
think is is lazy in this way but
whatever please participate in our poll
Ampersand as a thank you comma
send you a free gift right also there's
no period at the end there's a question
well I mean [__] there's a lot of things
Jesus man but it's it's hilarious that
this is a true social ad on his feed
because that's the only feed I go to
over there is just his just to see his
ranty
I got it there it is okay okay ready I'm
gonna click through yeah go ahead let's
see what let's see what the hell I have
I have an ad blocker on my on my
computer oh oh here we go okay it's
american-savings.com that's the main URL
supporters the poll takes you to what
URL yeah it's American American Dash
savings.com you want to go to the
website no okay all right no I don't I
don't I don't know it's American
American
Dash like a like a like like a Bank
savings account or saving like saving
Americans This is what it says right
here I'm gay right it's Trump twenty so
wait it even says Trump 2024 on it yeah
it says Trump supporters colon take our
short poll to receive a free do they
know how they know you're how do they
know you're a trump supporter well
because I clicked through the ad well I
know why but what does that have to do
with you being they're just assuming
that everyone's a trump supporter are
they are they assuming that only stupid
people would click on that end yeah and
unfortunately I'm one of those stupid
people it feels like you're like oh we
got they're like oh we got someone in
California yes it really it really does
feel like it really does feel like
they're like oh we're totally gonna just
say you're a trump supporter because no
one else is gonna click on that [__]
ad so no way is anyone else gonna buy
this grip it's like somebody click this
thing well let me tell you I am just for
I'm just running an experiment here okay
it's for science right all right so it
says Trump 2024 like the banner it says
save America again so
we saved it then it doesn't make any
sense did it get unsaved is that he was
so bad at saving it that I'm taking by
taking this poll you agree to the again
no comma but I take this full comma you
agree to the following uh one you will
answer all questions truthfully and
without bias
to avoid skewing results oh yeah okay
wink wink in other words in other words
hey in other words hey you could skew
the results by taking it more than once
by the way
uh number three you will redeem a
maximum of three free gifts per
household in parentheses supplies are
limited and we want all support so no
one's getting any gifts ever in this
thing you agree to all the items above
please proceed to take this poll and see
if you're eligible
does Trump have your vote for 2024 I'll
just say yes for the suit you know
uh is Trump innocent of course he is
no and they they keep switching right so
it's like yes yes and they switch this
answer to be no are you happy with the
current economy no is the first answer
thank you select a gift
and then I get this thing that comes to
a page here which you can't see but it
says uh Trump supporters again
americansavings.com thank you for
participating in our poll you are a true
American Patriot and are eligible to
select up to three gifts get the
strategy Trump uses to protect his own
assets so this is trying to sell me oh
Jesus Christ now he's trying to stay at
Trump University thing oh my God look at
this it goes are are your finances
protected from Biden's economy Trump has
exposed an IRS loophole that patriotic
Americans are using to secure the
financial he's telling people this ad is
telling people how to commit tax fraud
commit tax fraud right then that's the
exact person you want to listen to is
someone who's who's indicted on on 34
count felony counts of business fraud
yeah let's see in New York like that's
the guy it was clear it was clear it was
getting closer down oh it's speaking on
damn I turned anyways now you're just
showing your there we go yeah then you
go there and you sign up and it's this
whole thing and you get a free three
free watch uh wealth protection kit so
it's literally just it's literally just
it's just a financial services thing
savings account owners getting up to ten
thousand dollars or more in free silver
uh Patriots only debt relief offers free
service to help with debt it's a skin
Trump Goldberg are you screenshotting at
Edward says Gabe you need to screenshot
that and post yeah yeah I I I will
screenshot it speaking of screenshots um
because we're we're running out of time
here I want to show you a screenshot
um from you were talking about the
Tucker Carlson thing the other and this
is the same audience that's gonna click
on that end
um so here is here's Tucker's email that
he sent out hey friend it's official
Tucker is back his new show Tucker on
Twitter launch tonight do you have a
Twitter account question mark no or
don't have a Twitter account no problem
here's how you can watch no payment or
login required so then tagger goes on to
tell his uh very very elderly audience
how to use the interwebs
um and how you can click on a link and
it will take you to a website in a
browser window and then you click on the
play button
um and I'm not she emailed this to us to
his uh his viewers he knows he knows
that his demographic are the people that
ingest or or take in traditional media
they they watch the show on their TV so
none of these people are going to have a
Twitter account right and he was like
look I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna try
and future proof this problem by saying
that I know that you probably don't have
Twitter but you don't have to join
Twitter
because that is true yeah that is true
and that's one of the points you were
making last night about this is that you
Twitter you don't have to have an
account to look at Twitter right you
have to have an account to like Engage
The like retweet or like or or put a
reply or a quote tweet but you do not
need an account to look at Twitter you
go to twitter.com and you can your
heart's content you can read and look at
all the [__] you want
right but like on Google search they
won't play a Twitter video on Google
like YouTube like if you go watch a
YouTube video on Google search it'll
play the [__] video inside
Google search because YouTube is Google
Google's YouTube yeah but Twitter it
just gives like you said a a like a
screen grab of a preview right of the
tweet and then you click it and it goes
to Twitter right it goes to it's just a
link to the Tweet right so he but he's
explaining to his audience how you find
the link and and he's saying hey you go
to you know white privilege tonight with
tuckercarlson.com yeah I think that's
the website isn't it white privilege
tonight yeah um yeah um so you go there
and then you click on the link and then
you click on literally yes tell them
click the play button
so this tells you not know this tells
you a couple different things yeah
number one Tucker is way out in front of
his skis on this Twitter thing because
he doesn't even know Twitter where the
[__] and he doesn't have his team with
him anymore to do this but the other
thing it tells you is that he's
terrified terrified that his audience is
not going to watch this thing yeah and
and I think that's why it landed so
haphazardly is because he's talking to
an audience who doesn't ever they don't
know he is they don't really listen to
him they don't care to listen to him
they don't really care who Tucker
Carlson is they care you know who
[__] uh Andrew Tate is on and who
Elon Musk is you know these [__] boxes
on Twitter so yeah I I think it's
hilarious don't worry I will have a what
was that breaking this down so it also
it'll also bring up the uh the potential
lawsuit that fox is looking at suing for
him breaching a contract so if you want
to join the patreon to get Early Access
go to what was thatshow.com or
patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez and you
can get all those cool fun things inside
Early Access as well as behind the
scenes as well as uh you know sketches
funny little videos I've got an upcoming
commercial again I don't want to say it
you know what it is I know but I don't
want to say it the people on patreon
know what it is we'll eventually
probably play it on the show they'll
play it on the show I'm gonna I'm gonna
film it this week uh or this end of this
week because the thing that I need gets
here today right the special effects I
got to add to it why you're on patreon
go check out my page two patreon.com the
Tony Michaels and also uh why we're why
we're giving Shameless plugs make sure
to subscribe here on YouTube to the Tony
Michaels podcast you don't want to miss
a single episode
uh every single weekday Monday through
Friday tomorrow
is Friday okay and that's Bonet of the
week so you can go to the YouTube
channel to the community Tab and vote
tonight for bonehead of the week you
vote you decide we break down
who the bonehead of the week is when you
decide who is the bone of the week
whoever wins you can also vote on
Twitter at Tony Michaels pod you can
download every single episode of the
Tony Michaels podcast on Apple Spotify
Google when I get done editing it in the
afternoon it's free 99 over there on
every directory you know if you want to
find a an additional place to watch it
there's a couple additional places
besides YouTube you can go to Facebook
just follow us at the Tony Michaels
that's at the Tony Michaels you can
watch it there you can also watch it on
the up wire so go to the upwire.com I
believe tomorrow the suspension is over
so we'll be streaming to the up wire
tomorrow
um so go to upwire.the upwire.com follow
the YouTube channel there just type in
the up wire on YouTube also you can
follow us on Twitch it's free to follow
us on Twitch and thank you for all the
support on Twitch we've had several
people re-subscribe with their Prime
account today you got to re-subscribe
every single month and we appreciate
everyone who has linked their Prime
account to their Twitch account and give
us that one free subscription it gives
us a couple extra bucks a month and it
doesn't cost you anything if you have a
Prime account so thank you for that you
can also find the directions to do that
uh at the Tony michaels.com that's the
Tony michaels.com and you can find all
the links there to all the social media
and everywhere you can listen or watch
the Johnny Michaels podcast because
we're going to be on every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific for two
full hours
tomorrow is Friday boner of the week
same time same place Surf's Up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[__] em
[Music]
Murphy's muleborn headass Beacon